الاخبار اهلا بكم كشف برنامج الجزيره
التحقيقيه مخفي اعظم عن وثائقه ومراسلات
سريه للفريق الروسي الذي اعتقل في العاصمه
الليبيه طرابلس عام 2019 وحصل برنامج مخفي
اعظم على مراسلات توفق تفاصيل الاجتماعات
السريه بين الروس وسيف الاسلام القذافي
لاعادته الى المشهد السياسي ويكشف
البرنامج عن وثائقه ومستندات لسيف الاسلام
القذافي تتضمن ادعاءات عن تلقي مكرونه
الليبيه وحوالات ماليه لشخصيات امريكيه
واخرى اوكرانيه نافذه
قال المتحدث باسم الكرملين قرار بولندا
اوكرانيا بمقاتله ميج 29 مثال على زياده
عدد من دول الناتو انخراطها في الصراع
وحذر من تداعيات ذلك وكان رئيس الوزراء
سلوفاكي ادوارد هيجر اعلن ان بلاده وافقت
على رساله 13 مقاتله من طراز ميكس 29 الى
اوكرانيا
اصدرت المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه مذكرتي
توقيف في حق الرئيس الروسي
ومفاوضه حقوق الطفل في الرئاسه الروسيه
ماريا بيلوفا وقال رئيس المحكمه ان
المذكرتين اصدرتا للمسؤوليه في الترحيل
غير القانوني للاطفال في اوكرانيا واعتبر
المتحدث باسم الكرملين قرار الجنائيه
الدوليه مستفزا وغير مقبول وقال الناموسكو
لا تعترف بالمحكمه ولا قيمه لقراراتها
قانونيا حسب قوله
رئيس الاوكراني في خطابه المسائيه اليومي
قرار الجنائيه الدوليه بحق بوتين بالتاريخ
المدعي العام والمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
وقد قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن مذكره
الاعتقال الصادره من المحكمه الجنائيه بحق
الرئيس الروسي مبرر وان بوتين ارتكب بوضوح
جرائم حرب
تجددت المظاهرات في باريس ومدن فرنسيه
اخرى احتجاجا على تصديق الرئيس ايمانويل
ماكرون على قانون التقاعد دون تصويت
برلماني وقد اعتقلت الشرطه اكثر من 300
شخص بينما دعى التنسيقيه النقابات الى
اضراب عام ومظاهرات الخميس المقبل وبينما
تتحرك المعارضه لسحب الثقه من الحكومه
كشفت مصادر ان الرئيس الفرنسي لوح بحل
البرلمان اثناء اخر مناقشات بشان قانون
التقاعد
يمثل اليوم رئيس الحكومه الباكستانيه
السابق عمران خان امام محكمه ابتدائيه في
اسلام اباد تنظر في قضيه تصرفه بطريقه غير
قانونيه في مجموعه هدايا الثمينه تلقاها
خلال رئاسته للحكومه وكانت محكمه لاهور
العليا قد منحت خان حمايه قضائيه لمده
اسبوع تحل دون اعتقاله في تسعه تسعه محاضر
تم فتحها في مراكز الشرطه بتهام مختلفه
الى اللقاء